hip-hop is also in classrooms helping
students learn vocabulary is a teaching
tool in 20,000 schools in all 50 states
it uses rap so kids can retain the
information and have some fun at the
same time David Beck now shows us how
the program is cranking up sound in
schools David welcome good morning good
morning good to be in New York every
teacher tussles with what's the best way
to reach a kid right to have them digest
and then remember what they're learning
heck even parents struggle with it well
one New York City based company had a
wild idea why don't we teach kids
through rapping look a lot of people
didn't like it some people even laughed
at the idea but we went down to Texas
because we found one principal who said
come let me let me show you how it works
these are fifth graders and they're
rapping to the rhythm of rocks
it's all part of an educational program
at George Washington Carver Elementary
School in Garland Texas near Dallas it's
called flow Cabul airy which creates
online videos about everything from math
y MX plus B the Declaration of
Independence was signed in Philly to
social studies for Juan Hernandez the
program puts a little swagger in
studying the way to get out my emotions
and feelings and expressing it in a way
through music which I really enjoy
one's classmate Allison Matthew was a
little embarrassed at first you kind of
dreaded it didn't you yes I did but now
watch a rap about math first it's
parentheses then XS gonna multiply
divide I subtract yeah you know this
teachers always say that they hear
students mumbling the song under their
breath during exams or different quizzes
or whatever playing that rapping right
yeah just rapper Ike Ramos has shared
the stage with Lil Wayne and the wu-tang
clan you know what's powerful about
music is that actually helps with the
encoding of that information into the
brain but also the retrieval of that
information became a teacher and a coach
because I love hoping these days Ramos
who's a former teacher and principal
fuses beats with educational content he
got a raucous reception when he
surprised the class at Carver Elementary
they have been watching his videos all
year although what's the balance between
that teaching standard and that artistic
standard can have rigorous instruction
without relevance what we try to do is
bring in something that allows students
to authentically engage with the content
[Music]
Bonaparte Napoleon so to merge academic
content with catchy lyrics rappers
partner with former educators the
curriculum developers are very involved
throughout the whole process Blake
Harrison and Alex Rappaport founded flow
Cabul airy in 2004 from the tower of
pisa for them the music is just as
important as the academics even if we're
making this song for a third grader it
has to pass the test of can you play it
basically at a party and you know will
people react to it and say oh this is
good music back at Carver elementary
principal Wendy Williams purchased a
subscription and incorporated the videos
into her curriculum I tell my teachers
all the time you are competing against
Twitter Instagram YouTube and Facebook
so you better bring it when we were
growing up our families we really sing
all the lyrics on the radio right and
they would always say you can learn that
and you should be able to learn your
lesson so my grandmother these songs she
told me that all the time
and that's what this is I mean seriously
it's always kind of like Peck is so
genius the body must be no more point of
hip-hop is the most stream musical genre
today but it has its critics I would
imagine not every parents got a glowing
opinion of rap I completely understand
but if you look at hip hop by words per
minute it's actually the word he is
genre
Ramos says because there are so many
words
hip-hop can cover more material than any
other job
[Music]
melody McAlister is the teacher of this
fifth grade class and she will tell you
she has seen the benefit firsthand in
how rapping connects the kids we don't
all look alike and we don't come from
the same background you know whether
they think you're cool or you think
you're crazy you know it pulls them in
right away talking about igneous
sedimentary and metamorphic that until
you get it don't barf it you can be a
rock star yeah team whoo can you tell I
enjoyed myself yeah by the way the US
based vocabulary has gone global they've
got this program in China Qatar and
Rwanda Wow yeah love those slow cab you
Larry guys and I like the teacher who
just said your mom said if you can learn
that stuff you can learn this too it's
genius
it really they see him sitting in class
and they're like plate you know singing
in their head like oh that's the answer
Boop let me write that down it's a great
way to remember it nice to have you here
that good to be here friends you have a
lot of energy happy Friday my momma
might say I have a little ADHD I did in
fact you say that well it's working for
you David it is it's working for the CEO
good story